all right tyrone hey hey
you know i was tripping on my mark look
i i was really paying attention to
myself you know and it's hard to look at
the picture when you're in the picture
and i have a lot a lot of resentments
you know and my resentments have me
doing things to people you know when i
was when i was about 12 man i just said
i used to go down south
i had i had two cousins there was you
know
outreach experts you know in college and
all that and i was young you know i'm
saying i used to always roam off into
the country you know what i'm saying in
the woods and looking for the cows right
so you know one day man they they had me
playing we were doing this i don't know
what they was doing there but it was
like
freddy krueger type thing healthy stuff
was like they had me in the woods and
they were shooting every
balls at me and i didn't know what they
was doing i thought i really thought
somebody was after me
because you know they told they told
grandma on them that they're gonna take
me out there and we're gonna spend the
night
i didn't know nothing about it i was
stuck in the woods for like two days all
night everything and they shooting
arrows at me
you know and i'm thinking somebody was
after me i really was
i really thought somebody was after me
and you know throughout the years i
really had a resentment against them
you know and don't think i didn't try to
do nothing to them when i got older
you know and but they was older you know
and something resentments turned to
anger man i mean throughout the years
when i got angry i had resentments that
i held on with things i still hold on
things today
and that's sad
you know because
i talk about how
family and friends
mold me into certain things
and and i hold on to certain things but
this is that part of the universe i live
in
i mean
i have resentments against myself
[Music]
that's why i guess i treat myself the
way i treat myself
you know i mean
if i when i if you did to me what what i
do to myself man i would i would
really keep my own ass you know
i mean
resentments man i know i didn't i got
back at my cousins when they got older
you know see i was i just throw darts
i was i was real good at darts
you know what i'm saying but i would go
around the house and throw darts at him
when i got older
you know
trying to scare him
you know and see one when i was a kid
they they got me one time
with a boy and having an arm
they got me right here in the neck with
a born arrow
and you think i don't hold on to that
i hold only things i did with my plan
what my parents
allowed people to do to me
i mean what
what what happened to grandma i still
always resent me and grandma up in the
past a long time ago
my half brother probably i don't even i
don't even know nothing about him no
more you know the boogeyman i don't even
know nothing about him no more
i haven't
i don't even know if he's still living
i'm 54. so everybody's dead and gone by
now but
it ain't no rest in peace
i'm not gonna lie to be rest in peace
i mean listen
if i go there where if i go when i leave
this this universe if i see him i'm
still gonna have resentment
i'm still gonna try to get that ass
because i hold onto things
i've been holding on things all my life
since i was a kid
and it's just
and it helps me feel good i feel good
all the things i feel good having
resentments i feel good being angry
because that's about my gender that's
probably my makeup i enjoy that [ __ ]
because it makes me who i am
it helps me keep going
you know i get to a point man i get to
i'll get to a
i'll get to a point
that when you cross the line with me i'm
a real pastor i say [ __ ] like yeah
whatever
yeah whatever man whatever
but when i cross that line
i want to hurt
somebody and when i want to hurt
somebody i hurt myself if i can't hurt
you
i did that
because that resentment makes me feel
like
so good
you realize it more than hurts i
understand it but i'm so conditioned a
certain way
i need that pain
and resentment
remorse help me have that pain
i hate to say this
i love living in the past
because i don't know nothing about no
future
see in the present
helps the past because the past bring
the pain to me today
i love pain i love having resentments
because it helped me keep going keep
trying to get trying to get your ass
because it helped me to have something
to live up
and i know that sound crazy i know
but it is what it is
i need something to live for man i ain't
got nothing to live for
i got nothing to live for man
every day i'm out here doing what i do
every day
on a daily basis
so where am i living for
can't live for the day because ain't
nothing happening today yet
so i got to live in the past
so when tomorrow come today was my bad
so i lived for
yesterday to pass
and that resentment i hold on to every
jimmy to help me keep going cause if if
i want to get your ass i'm gonna get
your ass
so it helps me keep going
and that sounds crazy but god i am crazy
i really am it keeps you stuck though
it keeps me stuck but it keeps me going
it keeps me stuck but it keeps me going
it's the opposite of forgiveness you
know what i'm saying
how can i forgive but i can't forget
maybe yeah baby cool if i can forget you
you got to let it go man i didn't
i figured this out when i was five years
old and i just never ever held on to any
anger
mom
because it benefits you to let it go but
they say man it takes something longer
than others we have to be 80 or 90 years
old to for a year
i hope not you know what i'm saying
because i show ain't for you don't
forget you're going to go to vet angry
every day i'm saying
that's why i do what i do
my medication
i have medication i use on a daily basis
i listen to my music to escape yeah your
medication is correct crack cocaine
you know and it's a trip because i'm so
immune to it
it's a medication
it ain't like i go out there get crazy i
don't go out there and rob i don't go
out there and tweet like other people do
i do my medication
i listen to my music and i escape
mentally
and it takes me to another my body still
might be here
but my mind is on the other side of town
you know and it helps me
it helps me
like i said my mouth i'm 54 years old i
live with resentments and i hold on to
is it because it makes me feel good
you make me feel the way i want to feel
the way i've been feeling all my life so
i'm used to it
so am i wrong
because i want to feel the way i want to
feel
it's valid because that's the way i want
to feel
you know what i'm saying
it's valid whether i'm right or whether
i'm wrong it's valid
because it's my feelings
and it works for me you went through a
lot of crap in your childhood you know
and i hold on to that that helps you
deal with it you know
now if
if i had a gang of money
would i feel like this
if you had an army of therapists maybe
even if you wouldn't man
but see i didn't have because see you
know growing up
we get the oh oh oh oh oh oh
methods uh when you're sick
you get some whiskey and lemon
and your cold to be gone you know what
i'm saying when you do they rub stuff on
you when you get a soap
that's it oh oh remedies the old
remedies
and you believe in the old remedies
because it works because you believe it
you know i
today i got so many disabilities
i got a hernia i got penis in my back i
got congested heart failure
i got a plate here i can't even hold
that arm straight
you know what i'm saying
and i tripped on myself because see
i'm getting older
i forget things now
not getting resentment because i'm
forgetting things i remember thinking
two three days attack
i supposed to
two or three days later
now i'm having resentment about to
myself now
because if i if i can't if i don't have
resentment get somebody out here
in the streets i found i resent me
against myself i found out how to have
something against me
so i can get my feeling again
so i can feel relaxed with myself again
so i can get that medication again to
escape
again she had my music
and it seemed like it's a peace of mind
it's a trip because i get to sing it
and i'm flying
i really am and the resentment goes away
everything it goes away it makes me have
some peace some type of peace with
myself
that's important
you know
it works for me
but
i can't do it all day every day because
i got that type of money do it all day
every day
it's expensive you know what i'm saying
so since i got that type of money to do
all day every day
i need to get that feeling back and that
resentment
so i can have that feeling it's either
or with me you know what i'm saying if i
could escape all the time i would enjoy
that but then i'd be living in a fantasy
and not your fantasy you know what my
favorite movie i love harry potter
and i just say that because i know it's
magical it is and it's fast but i love
fantasy
you know my favorite hero is
batman
i love batman
and i got two favorite villains
thanos on avengers
i love thanos
and bang on batman because they couldn't
handle him
see they see
in both movies they had a resentment
against the villains
because the visitors were so strong and
they couldn't have them so they now they
try to have to figure out
how to beat the villain
and see i can relate to that [ __ ]
i can relate to things like that because
now when i got resented against you now
i got to figure out how to get you
you see that she said my connection i
got to figure out how i'm going to get
you
you know
because because you don't beat me you
did something to me you you know you
embarrassed me you did something now i
got to try to get you back
puts a fire under your ass you don't see
it
and it works
it works with me on a daily basis
and sometimes i trip on myself because i
go around looking for [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
because i see how people look i mean i
might go around riding my bike like i'm
on top of the world
you know i want you to say something to
me i want you to do something to me
cause i'm gonna get you back
i wanna get you back and sometimes if i
don't even like you i might come around
you just so you can say something
you're addicted to the anger
and it feels good
it feels good
because it helps me keep going
i ain't got nothing else to help me keep
going man you know what feels better
what'd you feel better i wouldn't let it
go
you don't feel good then you won't have
nothing if i let it go what would i have
i'd be empty yeah yeah peace of mind i'd
be empty though because the peace of
mind don't come to
my medication and my meals you wouldn't
need your medication your expensive
medication
condition we're going to go back to this
condition a certain way yeah no that's a
big part of it
and it's hard
ain't just an adjective when you put the
re in front of this word recondition
myself it becomes a
action word
but after 50 54 years
all of a sudden i'm supposed to
recondition myself
so now it's going to take another 54
years that i might not be i can't make
it to the 108 no i might not
just a match
so i better go do keep going doing what
i'm doing okay
because it's working
for me today
but see i can't live it today because i
haven't had no pain yet
i had no resentment against nobody yet
so i have to live in yesterday you gotta
go piss somebody off
i got to do something
so you so you can say something to me or
do something so to make me like like i
say now you're the villain
like i said man i love batman
i love man i love harry potter because
they uh they was always trying to get
win
but the villain always won the first
time
but then they get the villain next time
and that's how it is with me revenge is
sweet man it's sweet
oh it's so sweet it's poison it's
poisonous man it's sweet and it makes
you feel good when you get it no it
doesn't matter come on ma come on be
honest with me i don't buy it right but
be honest with you
when you got back when somebody did
something when you were younger growing
up whatever time whatever yeah
then you man you got them back didn't
make you feel all right
be honest yeah there's a part of me
yeah i agree
no but i i don't i steer away from that
all the time
i try to understand why they did what
they did and that usually brings peace
of mind
you have to figure it out because you
know everyone's doing everything they're
doing for a reason you know what
pop rest in pieces tell me
it's not they vote
because they're conditioned that way
yeah i understand that they could so i'm
conditioned my way
that conditions so i'm conditioning my
way so since you condition your way i'm
conditioned my way i'm gonna get your
ass back here here's what works in that
seven times out of ten
they probably had a dad who told them
they were a worthless piece of [ __ ] so
they're walking around carrying that
image of themselves that they're a
worthless piece of [ __ ] so that's why
they're behaving the way they are well
wow yeah and and that that helps you
understand why people watch it they
benefit from that what about my part
what about my side just take care of
yourself you know it's about me
it's about me mom
it's not about them it's about me with
me
so if you hurt me i'm gonna hurt you no
you no you just
figure it out and get the peace of mind
and walk away so it's gonna take another
54 years
it won't take 54 years
it could take five months
five months compared to 54
who's stronger
who's
is a 16 year old boy stronger than a
five-year-old boy
so who's gonna win the 16-year-old boy
is gonna beat the five-year-old boy
so a 50 year old 54 year old conditioned
man go out do a five month
man i don't buy it
i think forgiveness is pretty powerful
forgiveness yep that's that's why i
forgive myself today
for what i did yesterday well you have
to you have to understand it's not just
blind forgiveness i mean sometimes that
works but but what i like is to
understand
the
inner workings the hidden the hidden
workings of what's going on why people
are doing what they're doing why i'm
doing what i'm doing why everyone's
doing what they're doing
and then then you can kind of like oh i
see why they did that to me
yeah like when somebody steals your
hubcaps off your car you're like oh
that son of a [ __ ] or you could go you
know what the guy probably
has this terrible self-image of himself
he probably grew up in a terrible
childhood probably didn't have any
opportunity any way probably you had to
resign against you because your car
looked better his car exactly something
like that so you just let it go and you
buy some new hub camps and you move and
you move on so you're saying that yeah
so so you let me know more coverage
i need haters in my life to let me know
my accomplishments what's that i need
haters
in my life to let me know in my
accomplishment oh he got a new cop
oh he's uh he brought some new shoes
yeah yeah if you're addicted to hate
then i mean what i've what i've also
learned is that some people are addicted
to hate
they just they're going to find a way to
hate
and other people are going to find a way
to forgive and love and that's just the
way it is
you can't make somebody who's
going to forgive and love start to hate
somebody and you know because they
condition a certain way and you can't
take the hater and make them all of a
sudden understand and forgive and love
so so i enjoy the haters in my life yeah
it's like it's just we're there's it's
like republicans and democrats
you're not going to get one to see it
the other way no it's not it's just two
sides yeah and i enjoy haters because
they let me know i'm doing something i'm
doing i actually you know what i'm
saying they probably want to do yeah
let's do that you know what i'm saying
because i might smoke more medication
than they do i'll stand back and let you
do that i smoke more communication and
then they look at me like because they
mad because i won't give them on my
medication
and people like that yeah
people really like that that's pretty
common too you know
i mean man a lot of angry people out
there now if i was living in beverly
hills would i be like this
it's not about barefoot there's angry
people in beverly hills too okay so i'll
fit right on in
yeah he would you know i and sometimes i
think that's not about money everything
no it's not
it's not the last thing sometimes i
think about i said i should go over over
there it's just about peace of mind
that's what i'm saying define your own
way of having a peace of mind
your own way because your your peace of
mind might not be my piece of mind mark
yeah i know you know i might not forgive
like that i get it you know so if i
forgive okay
all right man he
i understand his mama beat him you know
what i'm saying i say that but i don't
mean that you got to meet it you know
you got to feel it yeah see it's hard to
feel
when you've been through a lot of [ __ ]
from a child yeah for sure you know
i mean some
some people don't feel
i mean i come and go with fearless
because i said i shed a tent in a minute
because i'm hurt
but it feels good to have pain yeah and
your 54 years of this
pattern isn't going to just change in a
day or two
and see and be honest with you i might
not be trying to change more
just just smoke it away i'm just going
with the flow yeah
that's the way you know what i'm saying
and they say man sometimes it takes
something longer than those you know
i mean i ain't saying something that
takes a little something longer than
other i'm all right
i enjoy the pain
i enjoy the resentment you know
i mean i enjoy the anger because it gets
i don't know
like you say putting fire on your ass
that's my fire yeah
and your anger can be a great feel
yeah you see
that you see what i'm saying if you can
use it positively it's it's not come on
over my fat mom no yeah
it worked for me for a long time too
so
yeah we can uh now you could i didn't
fix it oh yeah i did it i get it i don't
say no
it's a it's a powerful fuel
but you have to you have to channel it
towards something positive not just like
you know business just hold on i
understand that not breaking somebody's
name
but
when they try to break yours you i mean
you know i mean well you know what they
say martin luther king and macmillan
they always say martin luther king said
if they slap you turn another cheek but
backward man said now if they slap you
you slap him back
so what should i do so what you do mom i
would do the first one oh no no we gotta
talk to mug y'all we gotta talk tomorrow
man
you smack me i'm gonna smack you back
so how
why should i turn another c because you
might smack me again on another cheek
well here's how i see it so you hit me
you smack me as you say
i could smack you back and then we have
this fight going and then tomorrow you
might come after me or the day after the
day after that or the day after that or
if i understand and forgive and let you
go
and do your thing and you're not
looking to get revenge on me i'm going
to go to bed with peace of mind knowing
that you're not coming after me
and i understand why you did it and i'm
i have peace of mind you probably are
still like angry or worried that i'm
going to come after you or something
like that i'm not
but but but my way gives me peace of
mind your way keeps you in fear of me
trying my way gonna be like if you smack
me and i'll smack you water you're gonna
stop yeah but
yeah i mean there's different there's
different different ways to look at it
if i had if my smack is harder than your
smackdown
you know i'm not gonna say you're here
yeah let me ask you what i think i get
it you know what i'm saying and like i
say rhythm right or whether i'm wrong
it's valid yeah it's your way it's my
way yeah i get it you know what i'm
saying you gotta respect that too and
whatever people are gonna do i have to
respect that but at the same time don't
take me through it
because you're going to do something
don't have me going through it with you
but if i go through it with you i'm
going to get your ass right back for you
taking me through it with you or even
trying to take me through it with you
because i don't i i don't deserve that
you're gonna do the [ __ ] you go through
yeah and you're gonna make me go do it
with you i'm gonna get your ass when you
[ __ ] with me
shouldn't bother me because i didn't
bother you
that's the way i feel man
that's where i feel
you want to compare blood pressures
right now oh yeah i bet your your blood
pressure's a lot higher than mine
bother you don't bother me man
take me through some [ __ ] that you going
through yeah no i mean your childhood is
a big thing to factor in here you know
it's a big one
i don't deserve it so since i don't
deserve it i'm gonna make you feel what
i feel
life's unfair isn't it you know what i'm
saying they say life unfair you know
what i'm saying but you got opportunity
how the [ __ ] i got opportunity
and i'm 54 now
if you wanna give me the opportunity
give me some other get me rich give me
one high-paying job that i can see i
ain't gotta do a goddamn thing because
see i got some disabilities now i can't
do too much in that
i can't even walk 10 to 15 steps while i
stop and i got to stop breathing hard
that's why i ride a goddamn bike because
i can't get around
life is fair [ __ ]
you probably felt when i was young when
i had the opportunity to do what i
wanted to do but how can i get the
opportunity when i was young with the
[ __ ] i was going through
yeah that's the problem
so i went where where where the families
come in at
there isn't any
thank you
ain't no fairness
no especially when you had to go through
what you did
so ain't no ain't no fairness man
so this ain't no fairness and i need to
do what i do to help me keep my peace of
mind so i do the man my medication and i
escape mentally
that's my peace of mind with my music
but when you come in my domain in my
circle and if i mess with me
i'm gonna get your ass right back
cause you shouldn't have bothered me
because i didn't bother you
yeah i like i enjoy being about myself
man
and like i say and when i be bout my
[ __ ] game keep a peace of mind
do i do it by myself i'm gonna fight am
i having resentment because now i'm
thinking about my past again now i got
to keep going
got to keep going
and i'll be damned if i'm going to just
lay down
and down on my own
i'll be damned if i'm gonna let
let you take me out
i'll be damn stabbing
so i need to keep fighting
i'm gonna keep fighting you know the way
i need to keep fighting
you get that fire in my ass just like
you said that's why i get that fire in
my ass man
you know ain't nothing all right i'm
gonna come hard i'm gonna go real hard
yeah you can channel it into something
positive too you know what i'm saying
real hard
but right now i might not be ready for
that i enjoy where i'm at okay
i enjoy what i'm at i understand i enjoy
fighting against people i enjoy fighting
with myself
enjoy that [ __ ]
because it gives me opportunity to keep
going
that's where you're at today you know
i can knock my own [ __ ] down
you know what i'm saying but long as i
when i fall and i'm and i'm on my back
and i'm looking up i can get back up
but if i fall on my face i might not get
back up
might not get back up
because i'm looking down now i don't see
no opening
but when i follow my back i gotta open
it now i can get back up
i can keep going
i can knock my own stuff down i don't
need you nobody else to knock me down
but when you try to knock me down i'm
gonna get your ass
and that resentment gonna help me keep
going that anger gonna help me keep
going
on a daily basis
yeah i i ain't just been like i've been
like this for a long time
long time
and i believe it happened this is when i
when i was like five or six years old
you know what i'm saying
yeah it stalled me
because things in my life happened when
it shouldn't have happened and nobody
else didn't say nothing about it and i
was too young to say anything about it
and i better not say nothing about it
so i enjoy this
i enjoy
doing what i do
i enjoy living the way i live
and that's crazy but i'm a crazy person
that's all right
you know
like i say man
i hear people come out just the fourth
dimension we're in the fifth dimension i
don't know what dimension we're in
you know what i'm saying
i mean if it is somebody on the mother
god damn planets i sure would like to
meet you
i showed like you communicate with your
[ __ ] hand i show it like you
communicate just to see how crazy i
really am or could we communicate i love
crazy people
crazy people half the world go around
that's right
and people understand that
it helps the world go around right i'm
telling you you got to be a little crazy
yeah
it helps everybody keep going if
everybody go through whatever they don't
do help everybody stay alert help
everybody do whatever
without people this world do not go
around and everybody's not the same
everybody's unique everybody's different
man i seen the twin somebody just like
you over there but he ain't like me he
might look like me but he's not me
i'm unique
i'm different
ain't nobody like me and i re and if you
like me i'm gonna get rid of your ass
[Music]
because i ain't gonna allow nobody to be
like me
because we like me we're gonna bump
heads uh i've been i'm gonna be the
winner unless you you gonna be the
villain i'm gonna i'm gonna come out top
sooner or later
cause i'm gonna keep going okay go no
more
i enjoy the pain i enjoy resentment mark
and i hate to say it like that
you know what i'm saying but it is what
it is yeah
i think it's pretty common you know what
i'm saying
man i enjoy my marker man i really
appreciate you man i like you too you
know what i'm saying i mean i enjoy it i
enjoy coming because you let me express
myself man and i don't mean no
disrespect when i curse and all that
stuff man you know i just like that
really yeah and i tripped out one cat i
was up there
doing what i do and one cat looked at me
and drove up on me he said man
don't you be on uh
i said yeah he said man man
he said yeah he said he said man i don't
know the guy mark but man hey man tell
me
thanks for man let me share your story
man
he said man i went through some of that
too
oh really he told me that i was up at
the bank
you know doing what i do you know and he
said man
and my channel said thank you i i
actually i went through it too man he
said anytime i see you i'm gonna try to
help you i think talks like yours are
very healing for a lot of people man i
tripped out on that i did these people
these cats this girl and this guy was
long past that went up down there when i
was i was standing outside and i seen
her whispering him
she pointed me and i'm feeling like what
the [ __ ] i do you know what i'm saying
he said hey man you feeling them you do
right i said yeah and she said i told
you and i'm like i'm tripping
damn
i mean
it made me feel good
you become a little celebrity it's a
little celebrity i tripped out it made
me feel good man yeah people love you
you know what i'm saying i got this
other cat still serious down the street
hey tyrone
don't say my name man you know hey they
call me chicago out there in the street
you know what i'm saying i seen your
video like that
you know
and
sometimes do i feel bad
do i try to feel the best because you
see my video because i told you my story
now how do i now what do you think of me
you know nothing about me till you see
my story heard my story now now i'm
thinking damn what do you think of me
and now i'm waiting for him to say
something crazy because i'm gonna get
you away if you say something crazy does
it you know what i'm saying and they
don't say no they said mess in your
story man i like that you know what i'm
saying that and it's hard to respond
when somebody tells you you like that
i like that man and i'll wait to say go
come come crazy at you i'm going to say
something crazy or trying to do
something to you crazy you should read
the comments on your especially your
first video
man to boogie i'm like wow you'll be
crying
i just i it was hard to respond off that
mark
because they were so nice yeah
love is hard to feel sometimes right man
it's a trip how do you respond to that
kindness
how do you respond to that man
when you wait you should do give me that
back
how do you respond
with somebody very nice to you
you're not used to it
thank you
so i was responding
because i enjoyed
it
i enjoy the pain
ooh is somebody coming to different
you
i don't know what to do
i don't know what to do man
so
i just look at him
i said thank you
that's it
no
i don't feel like this
i like to feel the anger
i like to feel the pain
that's what i enjoy
so i don't want to feel like
good
i don't no won't you make me feeling
like that
i like fighting you can't fight like
this
i can't fight like this man i'm too
horrible
for god they never went out like this
i need to got my guards up man
i need to keep going
[Music]
i can't feel like this man
i need to keep going man i need to keep
fighting
i need my guard so
i need
the only way i can keep my guards up and
keep fighting because i have that pain
and
and that resentment and every muscle
that's the only way i keep going man
and i need that i need to have my guards
up man
because i i need these streets you drop
your guards they go get you they ain't
gonna let you give me
are you gonna
i'm telling you
[Music]
i gotta keep my glasses up man
i gotta keep him up
i gotta keep going
i gotta keep going man
in these streets man
drop you guys if you want to
you're gonna be six feet under
you'll come up
missing i refuse to have my
[ __ ] picture on that light post
out there all the goddamn milk carton
cause you ain't gonna be looking for me
like that because i'm gonna be out there
cause i'm gonna keep fighting
i refuse
to go out like that
man
i got to keep my pain i got to keep my
recipients man
that's the only thing help me keep going
and i'm going to keep fighting
because the
the community i live in you have to
fight
or you gonna fall
well i ain't mean no disrespect
i enjoy you man
hey man
maybe next time okay all right next turn
as always
you